[Música]
hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América edición nocturna me
acompaña en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches justamente en el
marco del día internacional de la mujer
pues hablemos de la participación que
tienen las mujeres en el campo de la
economía a nivel mundial Santiago y es
que aunque hay mujeres al frente Por
ejemplo del fondo monetario
internacional la Organización Mundial
del Comercio el tesoro de Estados Unidos
y el Banco Central europeo en general
las mujeres continúan siendo una minoría
en un campo que muchos siguen
considerando dominado por hombres que
elaboran políticas muchas veces
divorciadas del mundo real de iniciativa
de mujeres en la economía Busca impulsar
impulsar la igualdad de género en esta
disciplina según su índice 2022 las
mujeres representan solamente entre el
10% y el 24% de los altos cargos
mundiales en economía abarcando el mundo
académico Y por supuesto los sectores
públicos y privado los analistas estiman
que la falta de mujeres en Altos cargos
económicos desalienta de por sí a otras
mujeres
a elegir ese campo como una profesión
solo uno de cada diez gobernadores de
banco centrales en es mujer y solo el
15% de los ministros de finanzas del
mundo lo son según muestra este índice
las mujeres sólo han ocupado el 12% de
Los Altos cargos en 33 de Las mayores
instituciones multilaterales desde el
año 1945 y más de un tercio de esos
organismos incluidos los cuatro grandes
bancos de desarrollo nunca han estado
dirigidos por una mujer según este
estudio Jorge Qué hay de la región de
América Latina en cuanto a los cargos
directivos hay buena representación de
mujeres allí es alto el porcentaje bueno
Pese a que las mujeres han ganado
terreno en el mundo empresarial en los
últimos años este crecimiento se ha
estancado eso según un estudio de Grand
Torton a nivel global un 32% de los
puestos de alta gerencia son ocupados
por mujeres y el número creció solamente
0,5 puntos porcentuales respecto al año
pasado los investigadores afirman que
ese crecimiento se está estancando
Aunque un dato positivo Es que la cifra
de mujeres en cargos directivos en
América Latina es superior a la media
global el 48% de directores de recursos
humanos en América Latina son mujeres el
42% de directoras de finanzas son
mujeres el 33% de la ceo también y
ocupan el 34% de las direcciones de
marketing en las empresas Jorge Leo este
dato que usted me pasa por acá México
ocupa el segundo puesto regional como el
peor lugar de inserción laboral para las
mujeres terrible el panorama bueno Esto
es un analista de oxfam que lo atribuyen
a la desigualdad salarial y a la
violencia en el trabajo expertas en el
tema afirman que en ese país hay una
brecha salarial entre hombres y mujeres
Pero además las mujeres están expuestas
a situaciones de acoso de hostigamiento
y de violencia en el trabajo México
ocupa el penúltimo lugar de la región
con apenas el 45% de las mujeres en edad
de trabajar en el mercado laboral en
México hay aproximadamente 21,5 millones
de mujeres en edad de trabajar excluidas
en el mercado según las especialistas
esta situación evita que las mujeres
mexicanas tengan una autonomía económica
lo que las hace más vulnerables a
entornos de violencia y esto se
recrudece al llegar a la tercera edad yo
esto lo sospechaba Jorge pero Tal parece
que el dinero sí da la felicidad según
un estudio Bueno este nuevo estudio
revela que la felicidad aumenta
constantemente en función de los
ingresos y que esta se acelera cuando se
superan los 100 mil dólares de ingresos
anuales el estudio a cargo de un equipo
de científicos entre los que destaca un
ganador del premio Nobel analizó a 33
mil estadounidenses y revelan que la
felicidad y en aumento a medida que los
ingresos se acercaban a las seis cifras
Eso sí los investigadores descubrieron
que el efecto emocional de más dinero en
una persona es pequeño en comparación
con lo que genera algo tan sencillo Como
por ejemplo dos días libres el fin de
semana de hecho una diferencia de jueces
en los ingresos equivale al efecto de un
fin de semana libre para los
trabajadores quién se lo imaginaba vamos
ahora hasta chile porque allí la cámara
de diputados rechazó esa reforma
tributaria que estaba proponiendo el
presidente Gabriel borich bueno la
reforma la reforma buscaba crear el
primer impuesto sobre la riqueza del
país y financiar una serie de aumentos
en el gasto esta propuesta no alcanzó
los 78 votos necesarios para ser
aprobada y obtuvo sólo 73 a favor Aunque
el gobierno puede ahora presentar la
Reforma en el senado Es probable que el
descenso en la cámara alta sea aún más
duro que en la cámara de diputados el
texto establecía un impuesto a la
riqueza de las personas cuyo capital
supera los 49 millones de dólares con
una tasa variable que va del 1% al 1,8%
también elimina algunas excepciones
Fiscales aumenta el impuesto sobre la
renta para quienes ganen más de 5.300
dólares al mes y establece incentivos a
la inversión y nuevos mecanismos para
penalizar la evasión fiscal esta
propuesta de subir los impuestos será la
base de las políticas presentadas por
Gabriel boric para reducir la
desigualdad e impulsar los servicios
sociales temas que por supuesto lo
llevaron al poder hace apenas 12 meses
otro revés para el presidente chileno
Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización del mundo de la economía a
continuación en directo América ya viene
el debate
[Música]